[Applaus]
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
wir sind in der b12 und wir fliegen nach
gaborone mit einer schwer kranken frau
und die ursache ist eine
schwangerschaft die mich mein takt ist
das heißt es
[Musik]
entfernt werden
sie braucht weil sie so schwer geplant
ist ja der nieren versagen
braucht sie
diese betreuung hinterher ich bin
optimist und
die davon aus stabilisieren sie es
während des fluges und das steht in
gaborone
das weiterführen
ungehalten
[Musik]
frühmorgens in kansas usa die beiden
sturmjäger dominik und sascha haben
gestern in den wetterdaten eine tornado
zelle entdeckt dominik hat sascha vor
elf jahren zu hause in der schweiz
kennengelernt
mit dieser dreiwöchigen tornado jagd
durch den mittleren westen erfüllen sich
die beiden storm chaser jetzt einen
lebenstraum
[Musik]
der optimist das ist positiv dass auch
und das ist wahrscheinlich eine wie vor
ist das praktische intelligenz das
gerade so macht die nt niveau
fundamental bruma kitas durch die flucht
war mit opera verdrückt und weder der
winter hat er irgendwie so konvergenz
der winter so zusammenführen und steht
jetzt fest und vor allem spannend auch
die unterschiedliche haltung aber mehr
macht als gutes team
wenn jetzt der partner die natur sieht
aber genau gleich
dank sich einig ob maradona weiter finde
ich sie nie
[Musik]
das frühstück in nirgendwo ist
nebensache
die zwei sturmjäger lassen die
wetterlage keine sekunde aus den augen
probleme macht sich im august wieder
bessere luft
[Musik]
doch vereinzelt auch die bewohner der
seiten dass sie selber führt sie haben
gerechnet verglichen und spekuliert und
jetzt sind sie sich fast ganz sicher in
der nähe von augenthaler nebraska
entwickelt sich eine gewitterzelle zu
einem tornado
die zeitung
zur richtigen zeit am richtigen ort sein
darauf kommt es jetzt an
entspannter geht es bei familie moser in
südostasien zu und her
seit vier jahren wohnen daniel und
deborah in osttimor einem der ärmsten
länder der welt
macht nur um die mit der 34 jährige
berner arbeitet als missions- pilot bei
der christlichen hilfsorganisation mfd
bora kümmert sich um den gemeinsamen
sohn
[Musik]
da
die kunst orte hier in osttimor bleibt
die ausgebildete heilpädagogin tagsüber
zu hause
dabei hätte die ausschüttung wie schaut
hier aus mami filter ermöglichen das ja
nicht so dass man mit dir halt wenn man
daheim ich mit bringt also es ist auf
die vw kasse macht dich islam
das müsse mit dem auge für geist ist
sogar fraglich
[Musik]
deborah familie und freunde leben mehr
als 12.000 kilometer entfernt
so sieht es im team darf man keine
freundschaft doch noch das war doppelt
das finde ich sehr anstrengend
in argentinien genauer in puente die
linke steht dem schweizer ballonpiloten
stefan zelle die wohl abenteuerlichste
fahrt seines lebens bevor
gemeinsam mit 50 anderen ballonpiloten
aus aller welt bild stefan auf 7000
meter höhe die anden überqueren
avisiert habe ich einfach alle
sauerstoffflaschen gesehen von von
schoss aber ich glaube ich gebe die alle
mal runter da haben wir ein bisschen
platziert die ausrüstung ist erst vor
ein paar stunden angekommen sind last
für den staat hohe leute nachts da bin
ich mir nicht so ganz sicher ob das
funktionieren wird
bitte weniger kohlisch natürlich nach
wie vor dir viele nun klarheit darum ein
ziemlich gut aus diese auch noch -
rohstoff fleisch oder wenn wir nicht
wirklich aus in monique schickt einen
dem meer zu spanier denn er hat
natürlich fahre aber ich habe jetzt
wenigstens mal hauptkunde wo das zustand
ist aber jetzt mache ich doch mal auf
einen oscar alle können den ganzen müll
raus schaffen vielleicht diese unter den
müll jetzt viel zellophan hier
gestern hat das schlechte wetter für
dicke luft gesorgt heute soll es besser
werden aber ohne sauerstoffflaschen
nützt das alles nichts
wer hat denn die ballone gepackt war das
deine tochter oder eine flasche habe ich
dir gegeben die würde vielleicht gehen
die mir mal zurück
mein moment den mega stress chemie habe
ich eigentlich schon alles gedruckt da
aber die haben relativ komplexe sie
stehen des rohstoffs aber das kann ja
auch nur betriebe wenn die flasche wein
für war für systemisch denn da entlang
felski habe minar schlossen können wo es
gewinnt aber ich hatte eine grüne plane
man zweifle geschick der figur hat denkt
da war doch nett sie geschickt ganze
equipment spanier aber das wird alles
verpackt im container entdeckung neuer
tagen lineare den zügen oder zug ist und
das ist ja doch eine dumme nach region
wer das material gepackt in spanien
warst du dabei
wir haben 22 liter flaschen mit
geschickt mit dem ballon
wenn die nicht hier sind kann ich nicht
fliegen das ist ein hoher berg
mittlerweile sucht stefan seit zwei
stunden nach seinen sauerstoffflasche
perfekt passt dann ist es halt nicht
einfach nur ein ressort stoff flash
scheitern
im moment eine ganze flasche tun das
wäre optimal
wir müssen wir das amerikanische system
gekrönte grundlast nicht die selber habe
die idee der st galler sieht eine
möglichkeit die amerikanische flasche
könnte auf seinen schweizer schlauch
passen
[Musik]
wie sich vor der person herr otto halter
darauf gibt für mich zu dem zeitpunkt
niemals thema tiere auf dem hof geht
sich von dem was ich nächste woche das
ist garantiert oder bringt ist das für
die ok ok stefan will seinen schlauch so
manipulieren dass darauf ein spanisches
gewinde passt der perfektionist der
gerne immer alles minuziös plant
ausgerechnet jetzt improvisieren
isolierband auch wenn dabei nicht alle
verstehen was genau er da tut
gerade noch rechtzeitig zum
sonnenaufgang an stefan seine
sauerstoffversorgung testen
mit
[Musik]
ja
nun ist auch eher bereit für den
startschuss zur großen überfahrt auf dem
flugplatz amlikon im kanton thurgau ist
weit und breit noch keine sonne zu sehen
für jonas langenecker spielt das aber
keine rolle heute hat er sein flugzeug
verpackt und will damit verreisen für
den letztjährigen weltmeister geht es
heute mit zwei freunden ins
trainingscamp nach deutschland
vorausgesetzt der fahrzeugausweis taucht
auf aber es ist vorhanden ist stunden
später webseite die nicht so sicher
das ist normales fahrzeug
[Musik]
es gibt für schweizer meisterschaft ist
das training so wichtig für mich will
das ist doch eine zum trainieren gibt
noch viel besser sache und nichtskönner
1 1 es ist einfach noch nicht so richtig
wissen sie und einfach ja welches
vertrauen hat zum flügel und ja und auch
bestätigung fällig wo anderen das ist
[Gelächter]
mein lieblings weltmeister jonas will
hier die figuren der höchsten flug
kategorien limited erlernen hilfe
erhoffte sich vom trainer der deutschen
segelnationalmannschaft schausteller ist
eine koryphäe im segelkunstflug an dem
ich nicht ganz einfach sein wird aber
ich denke er hatte gute anlage dazu
angeleitet wird diese gesichter in der
schweiz relativ nahe am wald und an dem
mit für den aufstieg in die nächsthöhere
kategorie muss jonas ein programm mit
vorgegebenen figuren fliegen war jetzt
sagt das ist klassisches programm
zeichnet ein statement die einzelne
figuren
das ist zum beispiel christi roller auf
der route zwischen buchenau wieder
gestoßen
die sind jetzt ihre klasse spezieller
und die kann er trainierte und das ist
jetzt so richtig wusste was er vorträgt
dass ich der intensiven wie alle anderen
figuren politische lagerbildung
das schweizer team war in letzter zeit
sehr erfolgreich
niemand zweifelt daran dass jonas mit
der konkurrenz mithalten kann ein mensch
extrem viel talent hat das unterrichts
vorletzter hat da hatte weder sehr gut
punktete der neuen klasse zurück und hat
wieder neue figuren abläuft werden aber
schwenkers packt
[Musik]
jonas wird in seinem neuen segelflugzeug
auf knapp 1600 meter gezogen
dort klingt er sich aus
und jetzt trägt ihn nur noch der wind
[Musik]
aber was für die meisten imposant
aussieht hat für trainer legende
schausteller noch viel luft nach oben
gnadenlos spricht er seine manöverkritik
auf ein diktiergerät nach 25 minuten ist
jonas zurück auf dem boden und hört sich
die kritik an
[Musik]
aber es ist schwieriger
vorbereitungsspielen den flügen motto
figuren auch über reihten sich nun könnt
ihr als nächstes legen
aber ja ich das modellflugzeug sie und
jonas hat noch drei monate zeit dann
tritt er bei der schweizer meisterschaft
gegen die besten der besten an
[Musik]
die farm von mischa krug und christian
gross liegt im okawango delta eine
kleine oase mitten in botsuana
warum jetzt die schau lässt sich bewarb
sich sie ja und wir haben alles gerodet
aufgeräumt angebaut
die beiden weltenbummler haben hier im
afrikanischen okawango delta vor sechs
jahren die okawango air rescue gegründet
eine rettungsflugwacht ähnlich der
schweizer reger wir zum ersten mal hier
im 2011 waren hatte es kurz vorher in
sehr dramatischen flugzeugabsturz
gegeben im delta wo alle menschen die in
der maschine waren ums leben gekommen
sind es hätten leute überleben können
wenn helfe da gewesen ist und wurde
praktisch die aufgabe so in die arme
gelegt warum macht ihr nicht eine
rettungsflugwacht auf und dann
irgendwann haben wir gesagt ja warum
eigentlich nicht
also sie macht gott sei dank sehr
herzliche und du machst gott sei dank
das geschäftliche das ergänzt sich 100
prozent die okavango air rescue hat
mittlerweile 20 mitarbeitende mit einer
pc 12 liegt sie 24 stunden am tag
rettungseinsätze christian will seinen
betrieb ausbauen und bald ein zweites
flugzeug kaufen
darum braucht sein team neue piloten
die werden vom italienischen chefpiloten
aldo instruiert
darum zeige ich ihm heute das flugzeug
die p2 er hat noch nie eine gesehen
das muss er sein training machen um die
fluglizenz für diese maschine zu
bekommen
zuerst zeige ich ihm ein paar typische
eigenschaften der pc 12 und dann die
nächsten tage wird er mit mir fliegen
als co-pilot so kann ich ihm die ganzen
abläufe zeigen und dann muss er mir
zeigen ob er die maschine beherrscht
ich denke die größte schwierigkeit hier
im busch von botswana ist das wetter vor
allem der wind und die temperaturen im
sommer kann es im dschungel bis zu 38
oder 40 grad heiß werden
durch die hitze ist die dichte der luft
viel höher und das flugzeug hat weniger
schuhe anstatt mit einer schweren fracht
kam ziemlich schwierig werden
und dann gibt es natürlich die vor allem
beim start und bei der landung sind die
eine große herausforderung den zebras
oder elefanten sind wir egal
die bewegen sich einfach nicht darum
fliege ich vor einer landung zurzeit
reimer ganz tief über die piste
möglichst schnell und möglichst tief um
sie zu erschrecken aber die denken nur
geweckt das ist mein platz
schon als ich zum ersten mal mit einer
pc 12 geflogen bin dachte ich das ist
eine fantastische maschine du kannst sie
sehr hoch fliegen oder auch sehr tief
sie ist schnell und hat einen starken
motor
natürlich ist sie kein jet aber für eine
propellermaschine ist sieht ob allen
berechnungen zum trotz dominik und
sascha sind nicht dort gelandet wo sie
hinwollen
seit stunden jagen sie eine
gewitterzelle hinterher
in der hoffnung dass ein tornado draus
wird dominique überprüft laufend die
wetterdaten
[Musik]
das erhöht
der elch geprägt hat verschiedenste
energiewerke nord vorgang zu zeigen
das wird dann auch
acht stunden fahrt für ein paar
regentropfen die luft bei dem tornado
jeder ist raus das was ich mit
selbstverständlich dass man tolle box
set im juni erst einmal überholt
also man muss also eine quitte mich sehr
schöne bilder
und da sind und tornados einfach zurück
trotzdem die zwei freunde sind
enttäuscht sie wollten heute einen
tornado fotografieren
damit der tag nicht ganz verloren ist
halten sie an um ein paar gewitter fotos
zu machen
wenn ihr am fotografieren bhi im
europa-park sein
grund ist eine plötzliche ist dass sie
mit ihrer körper gateway nahm nach
rosenheim ist mittelstand weniger groß
als wenn er hier direkt entlang geht und
wenn ich sie so zweimal hat der plätze
kommentar liebe da unterdessen
widerstand nicht so groß und der westen
hätte das problem aber die blitze
bleiben glücklicherweise am horizont und
sauberen dafür ein wunderschöner abend
stimmung herbei
[Musik]
die szenerie also sich wirklich kennen
ja auch die sie immer schön steigen
gleich die erste bier erwartet dass es
doch noch
[Musik]
rücksicht
strahlend blauer himmel im segel
trainingscamp im deutschen walldürn
jonas lässt den tag langsam angehen
[Gelächter]
ich bin nicht mal aufwecken figur
antrainiert im kopf hab ich mir ganz
schön soll das uniklinikum fertig löcher
in die luft gestarrt jonas will
schließlich schweizer meister werden
schwieriges umfeld segelkunstflug auf
höchstem niveau braucht nicht nur talent
sondern auch enorm viel training dazu
eine gute mentale vorbereitung
körperbeherrschung und atemtechnik
in drei monaten tritt jonas in der
höchsten flug kategorie an
die neuen schwierigen figuren machen ihm
noch zu schaffen
er muss sie präzise und elegant fliegen
um an der schweizermeisterschaft
genügend punkte zu machen
aber trainer schorsch hat auch heute
wieder viel auszusetzen war senkrechte
da oder auch ganz wenig liebe wegen
jetzt stehst du kannst deutlich über
sehen gleich zwei weibchen das hat man
also schon von rom aus gesehen so früh
eingefangen
zurück auf dem boden ist jonas noch
zuversichtlich deutlich besser als
bisher
es geht sich um einige sachen aber mit
dem letzten flug denkt wir sind dass so
ein unterschied dann holt er sich das
feedback des trainers auf dem
diktiergerät
ganz deutlich über den bald einmal oben
ausgesehen
angefangen im quer- oder sehr viel
nachgestellte sein oder aber noch stehen
lassen dadurch 3 400 trainingsflüge in
den nächsten zwei drei jahren damit hier
eine präzision main kommt wie gesagt er
fliegt ein einigermaßen gutes standard
aber er fliegt noch keine acht oder neun
figuren und liegt auch noch ja gut das
ist jetzt gewonnen training fliegt auch
noch viele dinge ein bisschen zu unruhig
man muss noch ruhe einbringen eleganz
reinbringen
diese harsche kritik ist jonas nicht
gewohnt in drei monaten findet die
schweizer meisterschaft statt
der junge weltmeister reist mit einem
unguten gefühl zurück in die schweiz
dort teilt jonas sich seit kurzem eine
wohnung mit seiner freundin anna die
beiden sind schon seit sechs jahren
zusammen
anna weiß dass jonas größte leidenschaft
immer das fliegen sein wird zeit um
etwas gemeinsames zu unternehmen bleibt
dem jungen paar wenig wenig einfluss
[Gelächter]
nehmen sie sich mit her
ob es dafür reichen wird jonas weiß dass
er noch sehr viel trainieren muss um in
der höchsten kategorie fliegen zu können
wenn daniel moser startet dann geht es
nicht um einen wettbewerb sondern um
leben und tod
der berner ist missions- pilot für die
internationale christliche
hilfsorganisation msf in osttimor einer
halbinsel in südostasien
[Musik]
heute muss er zwei patienten
transportieren
ein elfjähriger junge mit verdacht auf
dengue fieber und ein kleines
neugeborenes mit atemnot müssen ins
spital
[Musik]
die straßen sind schlecht so kommt nur
ein flug transport in frage aber die
propellermaschine kann höchstens fünf
personen mitnehmen
schwangere lüthi netz tancredi aktiv und
autos sich vorteilhaft wenn ja welche
situationen bitte plan tennis aber man
sich heute mit der clique wenn irgendwie
ins gesicht oder aber ich denke es
oftmals berliner ganz klinisch sie eine
hommage das clean of time und welche
aber kämpfte mit den tränen und ja ich
habe gar nicht so sehr schön
der schweizer hat gelernt mit den oft
belastenden situationen seines
berufsalltags umzugehen als rettungs
pilot muss daniel pragmatisch
entscheiden
emotionen haben im cockpit nichts zu
suchen
rossi dass das thema nach acht merkel
[Musik]
wenig weh wenn ich sehe wie singstar
party nicht und so die geschwindigkeit
nicht irgendwie das cockpit hofer
kabinetts damit bestehe die gefahr
einfach weg zurück und sucht plant das
problem hier ist das kann ihnen
tagtäglich denen wir konfrontiert
der blick noch mal ein blick und das ist
stand partie ja nicht selbstverständlich
dass wir alle hier und das nicht gut
geht und support verhindern gestützt
[Musik]
wir freuen
ist schon schwierig ob die beiden kinder
überleben werden wird daniel erst in ein
paar tagen erfahren
[Musik]
ich glaube das war ein schwarzer vw
sachsen hat
jedes mal wenn es nicht klappt das
internet macht dalí wenn du hast hier
stürme nicht wenn das die rumänische
rasiere ich die großeltern in der
schweiz sind den kleinen kino einmal pro
woche über das internet die sich
sozusagen für pflegende dass das wort ja
definitiv kommen die nicht zurück weil
weißwein
[Musik]
in argentinien ist es endlich soweit
stephan und sein team starten zufahrt
über die anden
der startplatz liegt auf 2500 meter höhe
aber die ballonteams wollen noch viel
weiter hinauf bis auf 7000 meter werden
sie steigen
[Musik]
und die sauerstoffflasche funktioniert
hier über die ohren jetzt hier unten
fest steht sich
[Musik]
600 mit schuldig und stieg mit
zweieinhalb bis drei meter haben wir
jetzt den ungefähr aufgibt
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
obwohl stefan in 20 jahren rund 2000
fahrten gemacht hat geht für ihn heute
ein traum in erfüllung
[Musik]
sich fühlen wie wir wären acht und damit
plan
[Musik]
und nächste woche bei schweizer helden
der lüfte
dominik sascha finden eine gewitterzelle
und versuchen ihre konkurrenz abzuhängen
wenn ihr wohl kalkuliert schnelles
fahren ob namens kate
stefan gerät über den anden in
turbulenzen
noch sind ja 2006
konsumenten möglich werden jonas erhält
einen anruf der alle seine pläne über
den haufen wirft wenn ich jetzt für alle
flüge die angemieteten scheune ich
natürlich einen schweizer meister
[Musik]
und mich hat eine notfall auf einer
safari range
[Musik]